eine gedenkfeier an den sieg der
sowjetunion im zweiten weltkrieg
es ist siebter november dieses jahres
seit zehn jahren lebe ich als
korrespondent in moskau
hier auf dem roten platz war ich
erstmals anfang der 90er jahre wie viele
westliche besucher fasziniert von den
neuen russischen freiheiten
jetzt marschieren wir an genosse stalin
vorbei und dann zeigen wir allen hier
und allen an der front dass wir die
avantgarde der mächtigen roten armee
sind wir werden den feind vernichten
genossen
hurra diese geschichts fanatiker haben
die sowjetunion noch selber miterlebt
aber die jungen menschen hier kennen das
einstige kommunistische imperium nur vom
hörensagen ein imperium das von 25
jahren endgültig auseinander gebrochen
war
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mehr als die hälfte der russinnen und
russen geben inzwischen an dass sie
diesen zusammenbruch heute bedauern was
bei uns im westen 1 fiel das reich des
bösen galt ruft im heutigen russland oft
nostalgie hervor
ich frage mich was vermissen die
menschen soziale sicherheiten eine
gemeinsame ideologie oder die tatsache
kein imperium mehr zu sein
fragen auf die ich dieses jahr in
russland antworten suchte
es waren dramatische stunden genau vor
25 jahren zum jahreswechsel moskau stand
im brennpunkt des welt interesses die
denkmäler für die kultfiguren des
kommunismus wie hier geheimdienst
gründer felix erschien ski vielen der
sowjetische präsident michail
gorbatschow hatte mir mehr von seiner
macht verloren
er war einst angetreten für eine öffnung
gegenüber dem westen und mehr
transparenz und freiheit innerhalb der
sowjetunion
doch die zügel entglitten sowjetische
teilrepublik und erklärten ihre
unabhängigkeit und in russland selber
erklärte reformorientierte wolle sie in
das zepter
am 25 dezember 1991 hatte gorbatschow
seinen letzten arbeitstag an silvester
oder die sowjets fahne über dem kreml
eingeholt der arbeiter- und bauernstaat
hörte auf zu existieren heute noch
trifft man aber in russland ständig und
überall auf symbole der sowjetunion
schon oft bin ich an ihnen
vorbeigegangen zb in den pompösen
stationen der moskauer metro
die bis heute den namen von wladimir
lenin trägt
[Musik]
in der station des revolutionsplatz es
sind im kunst stil des sozialistischen
realismus vorbilder und helden im
sowjetischen sinne zu sehen
[Musik]
arbeiter bauern sportler oder
berufstätige frauen und natürlich kämpfe
und soldaten der roten armee einst die
größte armee der welt
militärische größe ist 25 jahre nach dem
sowjet ende wieder ein zentrales ziel
des kremls und das ist fast überall in
der gesellschaft spürbar
[Musik]
so wie hier im juni falschen grenadiere
der russischen armee treten zum früh
tonnen an
an einem ungewöhnlichen ort am rock open
air namens nach außerhalb moskaus einem
der größten konzerte events russlands
die armee präsentiert sich hier schon
zum vierten mal in folge
fallschirmspringen waffen flugzeug
schoss
gemeinsam sind wir eine kraft lautet das
offizielle motto dieser zusammenarbeit
[Musik]
ich frage den armeesprecher wie viel
daran propaganda sei es handelt sich
hier nicht nur militarisierung der
gesellschaft
wir informieren nur was die armee tut
und wir werben auch niemand nach
diese armee vom rock open air ist ein
beweis dafür
die russische armee steht heute wohl so
gut da wie noch nie seit dem ende der
sowjetunion
laut umfragen fühlen sich über 80
prozent der bevölkerung mut von ihr
verteidigt ich selber kämpfen natürlich
nicht aber auf unsere armee bin ich
schon stolz
die hat viel erreicht inzwischen 60
prozent der russen befürworten die
obligatorische dienstpflicht vor zehn
jahren waren die große mehrheit noch
dagegen
ein grund für das bessere image viel
bessere bezahlung bessere ausrüstung und
wenige skandale um misshandlungen in den
kasernen die armee macht aus jungen
richtige männer und wenn es krieg gibt
dann kämpfen wir gemeinsam
[Musik]
das beeindruckt sogar die rocken
sängerinnen wie olga corinna stand in
den späten jahren der sowjetunion für
neue westlich orientierte freiheiten
aber heute stört es sie nicht wenn sich
die armee auf dem festivalplatz
breitmacht im gegenteil
damals wurde nicht nur die sowjetunion
aufgeteilt es taten sich überall gräben
in der gesellschaft auf jetzt warten wir
alle wieder zusammen
die armee galt in der gesellschaft
jahrelang überhaupt nichts als ob es sie
nicht geben würde jetzt wollen sie
wieder zur alten grösse zurück die
popularität hängt auch mit jedem
vermeintlich größten erfolg zusammen der
annexion der ukrainischen halbinsel krim
dass putins armee illegal in der ukraine
kämpft und beim luftwaffen einsatz im
süden viele zivilisten ums leben kommen
ist kein thema 90 der posten beziehen
ihre informationen über das staatliche
fernsehen und die dortige propaganda ist
heute wohl die stärkste waffe des kremls
[Musik]
die rote armee der sowjetunion einst mit
über vier millionen soldaten die größte
der welt
das wahnwitzige wettrüsten mit dem
westen war aber mit eine ursache für den
späteren wirtschaftlichen ruin des
landes in den postsowjetischen 90er
jahren war die russische armee von
zerfall chaos und korruption geprägt die
verlustreichen kriege ging das
abtrünnige tschetschenen gelten bis
heute als symbol dafür
seit 2008 hat präsident wladimir putin
seine streitkräfte radikal modernisiert
kleine schneller flexibler rund eine
million soldaten zählt die armee die
mehrheit sind heute beruf sondern vor
vier jahren kündigt der präsident putin
ein zitat beispielloses auf
rüstungsprogramm an 600 milliarden
franken auf zehn jahren ein
militärischer überlebensgroß auch das
teil des konzertprogramms der
martialische hurra patriotismus zeigt
spuren
freunde von ihm seien freiwillig in den
krieg in die ost ukraine gereist erzählt
uns alexej aus dem uran
wir wollten einfach herumballern und
sind dafür die ukraine gefahren heute
erzählen sie allen stolz von ihren
sondereinsätzen dabei saßen sie meist an
den kontrollposten mitfuhren manchmal
mit den panzerwagen in die stadt um
wodka zu kaufen
russische männer die es immer wieder in
den krieg zieht das ist keine seltenheit
da seien auch julia und vera und zwei
frauen die beide familiär enge beziehung
zur army haben
mein vater war früher soldat er hatte
zwei hirnschläge und wollte dennoch in
der ukraine kämpfen
wir sind einfach so einmal im krieg
immer mein mann wäre auch fast in der
ukraine krieg gezogen er trank mit
freunden in der sauna und ab in den
krieg
füle den russischen stil sinkt diese
band und dazu gehört wohl dass die armee
25 jahre nach dem ende der sowjetunion
wieder einen zentralen platz in der
gesellschaft hat
[Musik]
komm komm aus dir wird ein soldat werden
[Applaus]
zurück in der moskauer metro die
grubenarbeiter kohlebergwerke nennt man
heute wie zu sowjetzeiten schachtjor
sie galten als helden der arbeit weil
sie oft das sowjetische plansoll
übertrafen aber am ende waren es auch
sie die mit großen streiks den untergang
der sowjetunion vorantrieben
und auch heute herrscht wiederum
zufriedenheit
es ist frühling wir sind im kusbass in
westsibirien dem russischen kohle
zentrum über die hälfte der russischen
kohleförderung wird hier realisiert das
offizielle russland will weiterhin auf
diesen rohstoff setzen neue märkte
insbesondere in asien eröffnen
für rund zehn milliarden franken
exportiert russland kohle jährlich
und doch haben wir hier in der stadt
mehr studierten zu einer hochburg des
kohleabbaus nicht den eindruck von boom
und erfolg im gegenteil viele menschen
in der stadt scheinen irgendwie die
perspektiven abhanden gekommen
[Musik]
davon hält uns der 33-jährige
minenarbeiter romans juliane kopf jahr
bei dem kohlebergwerk befriedigt ihn
nicht mehr
was tun außer den kohleminen aktien
dieser stadt nichts für mich
soll ich ihn als verkäufer auf einem
markt arbeiten oder waren liefern ein
echter arbeit findest du hier nur in den
minen die kumpel im busnetz becken
arbeiten in stein kohleminen die
meistens nur hast du so wird zeit
stammen täglich fahren sie hunderte
meter tief unter tage
trotz modernisierte maschinenpark ist es
eine harte arbeit hitze schlechte luft
und vor allem nicht ungefährlich 2010
kamen hier den mehr studierens bei einem
unglück 90 menschen ums leben
die minen seien zwar sicherer geworden
sagen die verantwortlichen
dennoch wirken viele arbeiten nach
schichtwechsel nicht nur erschöpft
sondern auch unzufrieden
sie klagen über sinkende reallöhne
steigende lebensmittel kosten und
ungewissen zukunftsaussichten
und da ist noch etwas
er war der arbeiter männern den
bergwerken hoch angesehen und wir haben
gute löhne erhalten heute seinen die
chefs das meiste für sie ab
[Musik]
wir sind an einer kohleindustrie messe
in der region
die gute stimmung täuscht etwas denn die
preise für kohle am weltmarkt sind
schlecht
die besitzer der kohleminen meist
russische milliardäre mit großen
holdings rechnen knallhart sie
minimieren die kosten und steigern die
produktivität das alles so die kritik
oft auf kosten der mitarbeiter von
unruhen und protesten fürchtet man sich
dennoch nicht
es ist zwar alles möglich niemand kann
sicher sein dass das nicht vorkommt aber
im moment sind die tendenzen bei der
kohleförderung positiv seit vier jahren
schon bauen wir jährlich immer mehr
kohle ab die produktion wird aber die
arbeiter sind unzufrieden
eigentlich nicht verwunderlich in einem
land in dem ein prozent reichen 75
prozent des gesamtvermögens besitzen
so sind denn auch die klagen der arbeit
die wir hier in dieser kohle statt mir
studierens gehören immer die gleichen
es geht um fehlende wertschätzung und
soziale unsicherheit rund um
gewerkschaften die keine hilfe bieten
obwohl die löhne trotz hoher inflation
bei umgerechnet fünf bis 600 franken pro
monat stagnieren
[Musik]
daheim bei der familie von arbeiter
romans juliane koch
er sagt es um mode durchaus unter den
bergbau arbeiten aber die sozialen
umstände sprächen gegen streiks und
proteste den meisten steht das wasser
bis zum hals schulden hypothekenkredite
sie haben angst ihre arbeit zu verlieren
kaum jemand steht auf und sagt unsere
löhne sind unwürdig
zu sowjetzeiten wurden die bergwerks
arbeiten noch als helden gefeiert
und sie hat mir viele privilegien aber
tatsächlich arbeiteten sie in stetiger
todes gefahren die unfallrate soll über
20 mal höher gewesen seien als in
amerikanischen ihnen so waren denn die
vermeintlichen helden der arbeit am ende
auch unter dem sowjetregime unzufrieden
hier studierte von 1989 bis 91 wegen
versorgungsengpässen und leeren regalen
grosse streiks statt die sich auf die
ganze sowjetunion ausbreiteten
diese streiks hatten den zusammenbruch
der sowjetunion beschleunigt in der
derzeitigen wirtschaftskrise machen nun
millionen von russinnen und russen das
was sie seit jeher den schwierigen
zeiten tun
sie pflanzen ihren garten an so auch
romans mutter nina und sein stiefvater
juni/juli ambitionierte bergwerks
arbeiter erhält rund 250 franken
monatsrente
tomaten und gurken gehen wir in
salzwasser ein paprika petersilie
zwiebeln und vieles mehr schneiden wir
klein und frieren des 1
dazu ernten wir noch sechs sieben säcke
kartoffeln
das reicht für mich und meinen mann
schon sie nicht lange überleben sie hier
dem heutigen russland und wünschen sich
irgendwie wieder den sowjetischen
kommunismus zurück die ganzen ressourcen
wie gas öl oder steinkohle sollten
wieder dem staat gehört damit die
millionäre diese nicht weitere unter
sich aufteilen
wenn der staat alles besitzt dann geht
es dem land wieder gut
die misswirtschaft der sowjetunion
blenden hier dem russischen herz der
kohleindustrie viele aus aber
verständlich ist ihr bedauern darüber
dass sie heute in der gesellschaft keine
helden mehr sind als die kumpel früher
auf dem just während von ihrer schicht
zurückkehrten hatten alle ehrfürchtig
schaut die grubenarbeiter kommen aber
heute spricht noch jemand über ihre
harte arbeit tief unter tage
und dass sie dort ihr leben riskieren
nein das interessiert heute niemanden
[Musik]
wieder in der moskauer metro betrachte
ich geschichte die gar nicht so lange
zurück liegt in bronze gegossen einbauen
paradies war die sowjetunion nur in der
propaganda die kollektivierung hat die
millionen von hungertoten mit sich
gebracht und bis zum ende blieb die
sowjetische landwirtschaft in sachen
produktivität weit hinter dem westlichen
klassenfeind zurück jetzt soll sie aber
durchstarten die russische
landwirtschaft zum beispiel in diesem
hightech bauernbetrieb bei dem wir jedem
sommer zu besuch sind in lipezk
zentralrussland sogenanntes fruchtbares
schwarze land hier zählt jeder tropfen
beim melken dieser kühe gilt der
kapitalistische grundsatz den output
maximieren
dafür sorgt ihre besitzer den jewgenij
war keine seine 40 jährige russische
aromen
geben sie mir mal die produktivitäts
liste der einzelnen gruppen
schauen sie heute wurden bis jetzt 1740
kühe gemolken im schnitt gaben sie 32,7
liter und was bei den kühen klappt geht
auch bei den arbeitern
viele hatten früher auf sowjetischen
cowen gearbeitet mit fixen lohn und
wenig anreizen mehr zu leisten
landwirt dino war keiner zahlt
leistungslohn mehr kühe schneller merken
gibt ein besseres salär und umgekehrt
wir haben damit die arbeitseffizienz
fast verdoppelt auf einmal haben die
mitarbeiter gesehen dass man mehr
verdienen kann wenn man mehr arbeitet es
braucht ihr klar die richtige motivation
die peitsche aber auch das zuckerbrot
bleibt die frage ob die arbeitet das
auch so sehen
heute ist es besser als früher was genau
entschuldigt mich maßlos rund 3000 kühe
besitz torwart kinder die den
familienbetrieb mit jedem mann leitet
der milch durchschnitt liegt bei 9000
liter pro kopf und jahr doppelt so viel
wie im russischen durchschnitt war
kinder und jemand hat 1997 klein
angefangen
heute beschäftigt das unternehmen über
2000 meter weiter der letzte
jahresumsatz über 150 millionen franken
rüstzeug und know how für die der folge
habe sie sich im westen geholt von den
europäern kannst du die details lernen
das management und die effizienz aber
von den amerikanern die industrielle
tierproduktion glückliche und fleißige
menschen auf kollektiven
landwirtschaftsbetrieben so zeigte es
die sowjetische propaganda
tatsächlich aber waren bei der
verstaatlichung der bauernbetriebe
millionen von menschen an hunger
gestorben
gegen ende der sowjetunion prägten lange
schlangen und leere regale das bild die
planwirtschaft war auch für die bauern
am ende 25 jahre nach dem zerfall des
arbeiter- und bauernstaates ist die
russische landwirtschaft noch sehr
verzettelt flavia was sie lena und
jemand alexander bearbeiten bis heute
diejenigen zwölf hektar an land die sie
bei der privatisierung der einst
sowjetischen kuriose erhalten haben
da hinten haben wir noch gerecht dort
haben wir verschiedene setzen auf blumen
verkaufen wir recht wieder die freiheit
mehr zu arbeiten um mehr zu verdienen
schätze sie sagt uns klar was sie lieben
aber unter dem strich sei es auf der
hose mit fixen monatslohn trotz allem
einfacher gewesen fürs wohlbefinden was
damals alle mal wissen
heute kostet es viel nerven ach wie
verkauf etwas anpflanzen
ach dieser konkurrent russland verfügt
über um zehn prozent des weltweiten
agrarlandes aber die russen machen noch
viel zu wenig daraus das resultat
russland muss wie einst die sowjetunion
viele seine lebensmittel importieren
[Musik]
am einsatz von bauen wie ural kukla
darauf soll es nicht liegen auf seinem
betrieb hier in der westsibirischen
kurdenregion hatten sie von anfang an
schlechte karten wie sie uns anlässlich
eines früheren besuches erzählten nicht
einmal einen gas und wasseranschluss
haben sie erfahren wir beim palaver vor
dem haus wie ihnen machen vielen
russischen landwirten zudem lange
transportwege und das schwierige klima
zu schaffen
aber auch die hausgemachten russischen
grundprobleme teure kredite bürokratie
korruption und oft staatsnahe
grossverteiler die über monopole
verfügen und die bauern ausnutzen
für diese bäuerinnen bleibt kaum etwas
übrig es erstaunt deshalb nicht dass sie
sich nach den planwirtschaftlichen sowie
zeiten zurücksehnen
früher waren die löhne zwar ort
aber da hatten wir hier noch
betriebseigene geschäfte immer sehr
billig einkaufen konnte aber heute jeder
muss selber schauen wie er überleben
kann
es gibt hungerlöhne mit denen man noch
die steuern und die wohnung zahlen muss
wie soll ich das zahlen
diese bauern aus südrussland wollten im
sommer ihren unmut direkt bei der
regierung kundtun
sie klagten über kriminelle und korrupte
beamte vor ort die ein normales
landwirtschaften unmöglich machten
doch den bauern wurde schnell einmal
klar gemacht dass solche protestaktionen
in moskau nicht willkommen sind die
sicherheitskräfte stoppten den
protestzug immer wieder und nahmen
mehrere landwirte vorübergehend fest
und dennoch die russische landwirtschaft
soll gemäß dem wunsch der regierung zu
einer lokomotive der wirtschaft werden
für rund 16 milliarden franken jährlich
könne russland inzwischen
landwirtschafts güter exportieren sagte
präsident putin kürzlich das sei mehr
als man für waffenverkäufe einnehmen
[Musik]
für die agrarunternehmen mit ihnen und
sechsfache mutter die wfg new york ein
erster anfang an sollen bauern
versammlungen predigt sie modernes
management und zielgerichtete
staatlicher unterstützung
in zehn jahren werden die welt eine ganz
andere russische landwirtschaft sehen
[Musik]
das gefällt den präsidenten wladimir
putin hatte war china zu leiterin einer
agrarexperten gruppe ernannt
in der politik angelangt unterstützt sie
aktiv putins umstrittenes importverbot
für westliche land wirtschaftsgüter
insbesondere die russischen agrar diesen
haben dank des embargos viel weniger
konkurrenz
doch für die russischen konsumenten
bedeutet das oft schlechtere und massiv
teurere lebensmittel millionen
bedürftige rosten leiden wegen der hohen
preise ja freunde aber das ist nur
vorübergehend
das gibt uns die möglichkeit zu wachsen
wir haben zum beispiel in kurzer zeit
gelernt qualitativ guten eigenen käse zu
produzieren
sollen wir denn nur importieren ohne
selber zu produzieren
auf einmal haben wir nichts eigenes mehr
dann sind wir wieder geopolitischen
spielchen ausgesetzt und könnten
erpresst werden
die geopolitik die bis in den eigenen
hof wirkt es ist wohl auch ein erbstück
der ehemaligen sowjetunion
[Musik]
was wir jeden der helden der sowjetunion
vergeblich suchen sind zeugen des
glaubens und die religion für die
kommunisten war die region opium fürs
volk
kirchenvertreter wurden verfolgt
gotteshäuser zerstört heute hat
insbesondere die russisch orthodoxe
kirche aber wieder einen festen wenn
auch umstrittenen platz im staat
sie unterstützt die ideologie einer
konservativen und an die westlichen
politik
[Musik]
es war im frühsommer dass wir uns auf
die suche nach der russischen religion
machten in der kleinstadt reading an der
wolga die menschen hier sind froh
darüber dass sie ihren glauben im
gegensatz zur sowjetzeit wie der frei
ausleben dürfen
sagen sie uns viele von ihnen hatten bei
der renovation des kleinen kirchenraumes
freiwillig mit angepackt oder geld dafür
gespendet
[Musik]
der raum ist ein kleiner teil eines
ehemaligen großen frauenklosters aus der
zarenzeit
auf dem größten teil des ehemaligen
kloster territoriums hatten die sowjets
ein untersuchungsgefängnis gebaut das
bis heute in betrieb ist
für die äbtissin seraphina die dem
kloster neues leben eingehaucht hat eine
ungewohnte nachbarschaft
am anfang war das unangenehm du kommst
ins kloster und läufst an wachen und
stacheldraht vorbei aber in diesen
gefängnissen leben ja auch menschen
schuldig oder nicht schuldig wir wissen
es nicht wir beten für sie auch sie
brauchen hilfe
so prächtig sarah sophia kloster zu
zarenzeiten aus vier kirchen und
kathedralen kloster räume wertvolle
ikonen
doch dann kamen die kommunistischen
bursche westen in russland an die macht
landesweit verhafteten oder ermordeten
sie zehntausende geistliche und
ordensleute in ihrem haus auf kirche und
sahen ließen sie die kirchlichen
heiligtümer konfiszieren und zerstörten
tausende von gotteshäusern wie diese
kirchen wurden auch diejenigen des sofia
klosters in triebes gesprengt und auf
dem territorium im jahre 1934 ein
geheimdienst gefängnis eingerichtet die
einheimische architektin anastasija
terranova zeigt uns die überreste der
ehemaligen sofia kathedrale
schauen sie das hier ist eine
einzigartige ziegel gucken wir können
diese ganz verlieren wenn wir hier nicht
halt möglichst mit der renovation
beginnen
schwester seraphina und architektin
anastasija haben einen traum
nicht nur diese kathedralen sondern das
ganze grundstück soll wieder in
kirchlichem besitz kommen und das
untersuchungsgefängnis seine gebäude
räumen
hier wurden holzbalken aufgeschichtet
und angezählt
für die heizung schauen sie mal das sind
schon teile der decke auf dem boden das
macht mir angst
kleine schmieden im untergrund wir
selber das kloster territorium nur
zurückgehalten wenn der das verlangen
bittet und euch wird gegeben werden
heißt es einfach so wird die
gefängnisleitung nicht sagen hier das
gehört jetzt alles euch
das alles ist mehr als eine rührige
anekdote denn die frommen frauen könnten
das recht auf ihrer seite haben
2010 hat das russische parlament das
sogenannte restitutionsgesetz erlassen
dieses erlaubt es den kirchen den in der
sowjetzeit enteignete besitz wieder
zurückzuverlangen
[Musik]
dieses gesetz gilt als geschenk wladimir
putins an den russisch-orthodoxen
patriarchen kirill der patriarch
seinerseits unterstützt den autoritär
konservativen kurs putins bezeichnet
dessen regierungszeit als geschenk
gottes
diese verbandelung von kirche und staat
gefällt in russland bei weitem nicht
allen
zbv immer neue kirchen in parkanlagen
für unmut der anwohner mit
unterschriftensammlungen und protesten
versuchen sich diese zwar zu werden
aber sie haben meist die staatlichen
behörden gegen sich und müssen mit
aggressiven attacken radikaler kirchen
anhänger rechnen ja verloren das ist
nicht mehr euer land ihr teufel hier
wird eine kirche gebaut
verschwindet ihr verräter haut ab von
hier im frauenkloster in rybinsk alte
man sich strikt aus der politik raus
sagen uns die schwestern
es gehe darum dass die menschen hier
geben sie in frieden finden könnten
ich möchte morgen den gedenktag begehen
natürlich du kannst gerne vorbei können
wir frühen morgen wieder eine liturgie
bis morgen sehen sie mich bitte über 70
prozent der russen bezeichnen sich
bereits das russisch-orthodoxe christen
die meisten aber aus kulturellen gründen
regelmäßig in den gottesdienst gehen nur
sieben prozent
die rückgabe des frauenklosters in der
stadt die binz ist umstritten
man muss auch an die häftlinge denken
für sie muss man etwas neues bauen die
sowjetischen machthaber hatten nun mal
entschieden dass man kirchen und klöster
für andere zwecke nutzt das alles
rückgängig zu machen ist schwierig das
wichtigste ist dass das nicht wieder zu
konflikten in der gesellschaft führt ich
habe gemerkt queen ist das ernst
sie träumen vom wiederaufbau des großen
frauenklosters wie es zu zarenzeiten war
die renovation hörte wohl mehrere
millionen franken kosten
das muss aber kein unüberwindbares
hindernis sein
für russische geschäftsleute gehört ist
nämlich heute zu wort und ton kirchen
der innovationen zu unterstützen den
historischen teil werden wir so wieder
herstellen wie er war aber dazu käme
noch ein hotel und ein russisch
orthodoxes bildungszentrum die
finanzierung würden vor allem private
investoren oder sponsoren übernehmen
der staat hat sonst schon zu viele
probleme
und das gefängnis da haben sogar die
schwestern skrupel
wir haben alle rechte auf das gebäude
die gefängnisleitung wird sich bis jetzt
nicht aber sie müssten ein neues gebäude
finden das gefängnis funktioniert doch
fast wie eine kleine stadt
das muss man berücksichtigen nun der
bischof sagt die verhandlungen laufen
[Applaus]
die historische gerechtigkeit wieder
herstellen oder doch der einfachheit
halber die geschichte ruhen lassen
25 jahre nach ihrem ende ist die
sowjetunion auch hier schwierige fragen
auf
[Musik]
die russischen frauen sie sind die
eigentlichen stützen der gesellschaft
und das waren sie wohl bereits zu
sowjetzeiten offizielle galten sie als
gleichberechtigt und wurden gefördert
aber in tat und wahrheit waren sie
trägerin in der doppel last arbeit und
familie und sollten dabei ja nicht ihre
familien in seiten verlieren
hohe ansprüche die bis heute geblieben
sind
[Musik]
früher zu sowjetzeiten hätten die frauen
vor allem innere werte haben müssen
und heute es ist mitten im sommer als
wir an den miss wahlen im kongo filmen
einer stadt im ural gebirge
[Musik]
heute muss eine frau in erster linie
schön sein
talentiert und ja wenn sie gescheit ist
wird es inzwischen auf geschätzt
reifere frauen sagen zu ihrem zeiten
hätten halt die miss wahl noch anders
ausgesehen
[Musik]
natürlich hat es damals auch
wettbewerber gegeben
vielleicht hat man auch aufs äußere
geschaut vor allem wurde aber wissen und
können gibt es nannte man damals
olympiaden aber eigentlich waren das
wissenstest hat rund 70.000 einwohner in
landstrichen wie diesen sind die
menschen noch patriotische und
bodenständigen als anderswo
wir fahren vor dem haus vor in dem an
der börse war wohnt eine lehrerin und
stellvertretende schuldirektor in kundus
die hand zur begrüßung wird übrigens
seinen russischen frau nurdan gereicht
wenn sie es selber wünscht
sie wünscht es offensichtlich nicht
die 15-jährige mal diabolische war
anders tochter macht mit bei den
misswahlen die demut hat für den
wettbewerb monate lang leider
vorbereiteten
wir möchten den beiden ein video cd von
den ersten miss sowjetunion wahlen
überhaupt im jahre 1989 damals ein
zeichen der öffnung in früheren jahren
des sozialismus hätte solches noch als
westliche dekadenz gegolten
ich schau dir mal diese pfade kleider an
mit denen würden wir heute nicht einmal
mehr ins schwimmbad gehen wir wollen
dann hat er damals die 17 jährige julia
suchinowa
daraufhin reiste sie in den westen aus
ein schritt zu dem sich dann auch noch
viele russische frauen entscheiden
werden
mich hat mein mann nicht an solche
misswahlen gelassen
aber ich habe auch schon mit 18
heiratete zu sowjetzeiten heiraten die
frauen im durchschnitt mit 21 jahren
inzwischen ist dieser wert den wir
hinauf 25 jahre angestiegen
annas mann hat eine autogarage er spürt
die wirtschaftskrise musste seine fünf
mitarbeiter entlassen
wir sehen uns ja am abend liest er wodka
kaufen
wir hätten lieber moskowski
maria riesch war hatte vor fünf jahren
an der sogenannten mini miss wahl
teilgenommen
damals hat es nicht geklappt eine
riesenenttäuschung sei das gewesen wenn
sie hat große ziele im leben ein kleiner
traum ist heute den konkurs zu gewinnen
und der große traum einmal zu werden
vielleicht sogar im ausland
aber da muss ich dann natürlich besser
sprachen lernen
der alltag der russischen frauen ist
weit weniger glamourös sie sind zwar
heute besser ausgebildet als die männer
verdienen aber immer noch rund ein
drittel weniger
vor allem aber müssen sie weiterhin oft
die doppel last von familie und arbeit
tragen wo nur eine kleine minderheit der
männer nimmt aktiv an der
kindererziehung teil
ich sehe in der schule dass viele kinder
nur von den müttern großgezogen werden
die väter beteiligen sich daran nicht
sie sind vielleicht irgendwo präsent
aber sie fürchten sich vor der
verantwortung die familie zu führen
im sommer macht den sozialen netzwerken
ein tabuthema schlagzeilen gewalt gegen
frauen erstmals erzählten tausende von
frauen gemeinsam geschichten wie sie
gewalt erfahren haben
mit 16 wurde ich vergewaltigt weder
freunde noch familie wissen davon
aber solange wir schweigen wird diese
höhle nicht aufhören es solche gewalt
hier ein thema ich habe da keine
offiziellen informationen
so etwas hätte sicher auch hier bei uns
gewalt gegen frauen wohl noch immer ein
tabuthema
[Musik]
themenwechsel
über drei stunden dauert die miss show
in der provinz stand
unter den zuschauern ist auch tatjana
arcadium die großmutter von maria
[Musik]
die auftritte der teilnehmerinnen sind
nach länder sujets aufgeteilt maria hat
frankreich gewählt
[Musik]
ich hoffe einfach dass sie etwas
studieren wird und danach auch eine gute
karriere fürs kinderkriegen hat sie doch
später noch genug zeit oder nicht
[Musik]
die russinnen sind anders nicht wie bei
uns gibt es das nicht dass frauen sagen
so ich bin selbstständig und werde jetzt
alles selber entscheiden
bei uns geht das zusammen männer vier
jahren die familie
es wird nicht getrennt wir sind noch
nicht so selbstständig
ein wenig entspannung wählen die schüler
im hintergrund über die siegerin berät
es ist bereits neun uhr abends an die
entscheidung
[Musik]
maria hat es geschafft sie ist miss co
[Applaus]
der traum ist wahr geworden
auf den papa ist ganz stolz ein kleiner
schritt zu einer karriere in europa
vielleicht aber den heutigen russland
werden oft wie der neue grenzen
aufgezogen
zumindest im kopf was der vater zur
karriere in europa seit europa wird er
heute von den muslimen angegriffen
was sollen denn unsere schönen frauen
dort mit ihren langen beinen und kurzen
röcken weiterträumen soll erlaubt sein
vielleicht kommen ja irgendwann wieder
entspanntere zeiten zwischen ost und
west
so wie es sie schon einmal gab zb damals
und 25 jahren
[Musik]